indeed it's not easy to go through all
those events play those four tournaments
and still emerge victorious
congratulations wesley first of all when
you found out the news what was your
response
yeah i knew i knew yesterday fabiano and
richard draw then i would basically be
guaranteed no matter what happens
because even if i lose yesterday and
draw today i would still barely make it
but
yeah i was very happy and
i'll dedicate this win to the lord jesus
and all glory to him
but i actually don't feel like a winner
yeah
considering the way i played this event
as usual history happens uh history
repeats itself because
i usually finish like
last or dead last
or close to laugh in the think world cup
in five of my last six events so this
time i did a bit better a lot better
yeah you may be time for second place
yeah i'm a bit disappointed because i i
could have
i i i missed some chances earlier
earlier earlier on the tournament
uh today lanier is very solid and also
he knows all theory up to move 30. so
it's hard to get a game but
i missed some chances earlier in the
event when i had the white pieces and
yeah obviously
everyone wants to fight for first place
so i don't
really feel like i played particularly
well in my two tournaments here in st
louis i'm very happy and very fortunate
to win this
i know you said history repeats itself
do you mean in terms of your emotional
reaction to the event because obviously
the only history that's repeated itself
here is you're winning the tour
now i usually play bad in the thinkfield
cup uh
2019 18. so
i was kind of mentally prepared for for
a very tough tournament
uh
but uh
yeah i i want to congratulate maxim on
winning four games here it's very very
tough event and to win four games it's
pretty fantastic
also i'd like to thank the arbiters
especially chris bird for congratulating
me earlier encouraging me
my mother and also to you guys the
commentators for your hard work
and also grandchild store for for
for continuing and having this event uh
yeah i don't really feel like a winner
right now of course i'm very happy to
win extra money very good
very good
and i'll take the win but
uh i'm not very happy satisfied with my
play here
well if you're playing badly i i want to
know what the other people feel like
we're finishing behind you you were very
consistent throughout the whole time
you you did well in
uh bucharest yeah black one yeah plus
one you won paris yeah uh you you did
well enough uh in the saint louis rapid
and blitz yeah for it yeah fourth place
and now second place i mean that's
that's the mark of somebody who's who's
consistent
win is a wins one of the events and
shows that you're you're solid all the
way at the top
yeah yeah i think i thank you i think i
was rescued by my performances in europe
uh
but somehow in the last few days of
tournament i didn't have enough energy
like here to fight for clear first
um
guys is it me or the guy comes in fourth
place in one event and second place in
this event
or maybe second uh ty for a second and
he and he thinks it's a bad it's not a
great result yeah he has some very high
standards maurice he's got a very
earning so much money in three weeks
but also fourth place in second place
that doesn't sound so bad yeah looking
at it in hindsight things could be uh
things could be worse so actually if i
had to go back in time i could be pretty
satisfied with my results i mean after
all uh shakira remembers thereof one
bucharest nba wins the sleep hill cup
and you're walking out with the grand
chester title something's uh something
was that happened on the way to athens
well fortunately maxim finnish
died for left in romania so that really
hampered his chances
uh
but he's bouncing back uh
and i i i could learn a lot of things
from from my games here
all right well congratulations of course
on winning the tour title it's your
second tour title
joining only magnus who has done that
twice as well no one else has done that
so
definitely a feather in your cap yeah
thank you very it's very very big win
hopefully i can
play better but uh yeah there will be a
lot of tournaments coming up
for me so we have the 960 also coming up
so let me do it going to be very
exciting
all right congratulations thank you
mommy
our congratulations to wesley a job in
our opinion very very well done